[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
Brazil has just experienced the most
decisive moment in its Democratic
history the presidential elections held
in October showed that Brazil is divided
in two the supporters of President Jer
bolsonaro and all of those who are
against it at the Forefront of the
latter was Lula de Silva who had been
Brazilian president at the turn of the
century many considered him the only one
capable of defeating bolsonaro and yes
they were absolutely right in his own
victory speech Lula pledged to overcome
the division of the country into two
camps and to be the president of all
Brazilians
foreign
[Music]
of course the Electoral result was
incredibly tight with 50.9 for Lula 49.1
percent bolsonaro that it was so tight
and that the current president got a
much better result than expected in the
polls brings thorth many questions what
have been bolsonaro's main achievements
in these four years what mistakes have
caused his defeat what will be the main
challenges for Luna De Silva in his new
presidential phase today on
visualpolitik we're going to provide
answers to these questions
foreign
[Music]
Brazil was stuck in the past its
industry was protected by tariffs and
there were import bans on many products
in addition the country was facing
accelerated B industrialization
something that happens when your
industries are not competitive and that
is not all to make matters worse it had
accumulated four Decades of high
inflation to put an end to this
situation 30 years ago the government of
itamar Franco launched the real plan a
plan that was later developed by the
government of Fernando Enrique cardosa
and which involved changing the currency
and implementing a tax reform the real
plan was successful and Brazil became
one of the leading emerging economies
poverty began to decline and income
inequality was reduced Lula de Silva
then enjoyed a few years of economic
abundance thanks to the commodity boom
in international markets as a result
Brazil became the seventh largest
economy in the world in 2010 practically
tied with the six largest as you can see
here however it has since Fallen to 12th
Place in this recent ranking
when the oil Bonanza came to an end
things started to fall apart what's more
deliver Rusev's government was Lethal
for the Brazilian economy and it went
into a deep recession even the country's
largest company the state-owned oil
giant petrobras was on the ropes and
close to bankruptcy people's discontent
propelled one of the most controversial
political figures in recent years where
of course talking about jair bolsonaro
his populist discourse captivated
millions of Brazilians who were tired of
the numerous corruption scandals that
played the workers party after 16 years
of government however one of President
bolsonaro's greatest successes was to
incorporate Paulo guadus as a sort of
super Minister for economic affairs
[Music]
Paulo holds a PhD in economics from the
University of Chicago a model
Institution for economic liberalism
since he became Minister he has promoted
an agenda focused on promoting
privatization simplifying labor
regulations and reducing bureaucracy an
impossible mission from the outset since
according to World Bank data Brazil has
one of the most complex and inefficient
tax legislations in the world
specifically it ranks 184th in the world
banked ranking of 190 tax systems
[Music]
the labor reform promoted by The
bolsonaro guader's Duo has had good
results Brazil's unemployment rate has
reached 12 percent when both came to
power currently and despite the
coronavirus this has been reduced to
below nine percent the lowest figure
since 2015. another card played by
greatest was to bet on privatizations to
reduce public debt
to convince Brazilians bolsonaro has had
it easy but of course it was not
complicated to improve on the economic
management of his predecessors
foreign
however this desire to reduce the size
of the state Machinery came up against
reality it is true that it carried out
the largest privatization in two decades
but in the end it did not dare with the
petrobrass oil company so basically
everything was limited to a partial
privatization of electrobras the
state-owned company in charge of
electricity generation in the country a
privatization that attracted investment
from the Singapore Sovereign wealth fund
and the Canadian pension fund it also
allowed private investment in water and
sewage be that as it may the important
thing is that between one thing and
another the results came in
[Music]
the best news for Brazil is that after a
decade of weak economic growth the
Country Returns to reasonably good
numbers at least considering that we are
talking about Brazil a terribly
bureaucratic and unfriendly economy for
business even by Latin American
Standards well the pandemic drank Brazil
down by four percent in 2020 but in 2021
GDP grew by 4.6 and in 2022 at the time
of the elections year-on-year growth was
still above 3 these positive data and a
tremendously polarized discourse helps
to form a community of true Fanatics
around the president bolsonarismo
foreign
wait a minute it wasn't also Rosy
because the numbers are reasonably good
yes the truth is that the economy has
grown in large part thanks to the
government's stimulus policies
[Music]
in view of the polls bolsonaro set aside
economic theory and pulled out all his
artillery to achieve a comeback he
approved an aid program with lower taxes
on fuel electricity gas and public
transportation he also bet on improving
social benefits the excuse as you can
imagine inflation the motive as you can
also well imagine was to give a little
gift to the voters don't forget that for
politicians poor Brazilians have only
one thing that as much value as that of
the rich their vote so to achieve this
goal bolsonaro launched into extending
and even expanding the social measures
he put in place during the pandemic
bolsonaro raises axillil Brazil from 400
to 600 it was undoubtedly his star
measure we're talking about the fact
that this 50 increase brought auxilo
Brazil to about a hundred and ten
dollars per month
foreign
after the first round of Elections he
promised to extend this Aid during 2023.
the bill for this all is no joke right
now orcillo Brazil is being received by
21 million Brazilian families so
currency up currency down bolsonaro
committed Aid worth over 50 billion
dollars including new debt forgiveness
programs and lines of credit however
visual politic viewers all this was not
enough for bolsonaro he had many wrongs
to write and the election campaign
against Lula was like putting palmyra's
fans together with Corinthians fans
listen up
[Music]
The Two Towers
[Music]
Bolson arrows Administration has had
significant downsides denying the
importance of covid-19 made Brazil the
country with the second highest number
of deaths from coronavirus in the world
with almost 700 000 deaths downplaying
the importance of the upturn in Amazon
logging does not seem to be the best
move in an international scene dominated
by environmental concerns either and
arguing for an outdated concept of the
role of women in modern societies
creates an obstacle that a good part of
the electorate can't get past in order
to vote for you even so he almost
managed to win re-election in a
confrontation between the two most
important figures in Brazilian politics
so far this Century because Lula also
generates rejection from certain groups
[Music]
former president Lula de Silva was
imprisoned after being charged with
corruption in the lava Jato Scandal
surrounding the state-owned oil company
petrovas he spent 19 months in prison
before being released by the Supreme
Court which annulled all sentences
against Lula on the grounds that the
matter was beyond the jurisdiction of
the judge who had convicted him in other
words Lula was released because of a
technical defect in the judicial process
to which he was subjected not because
the Supreme Court considered him
innocent of the accusations against him
something for which he will never be
tried because the statute of limitations
has already expired
memory has played in Lula's favor among
many voters during his presidency the
quality of life of millions of
Brazilians improved considerably and you
have to remember that no matter how much
money bolsonaro released just before the
elections those who received the aid are
the same ones who are angry about the
rise in inflation
as you can imagine we are talking about
two politicians who leave no one
indifferent and that has been noticed in
the Electoral campaigns where all limits
have been exceeded now if bolsonaro has
a reputation for disrespecting his
political Rivals don't think that Lula
has been left behind Brazil judge
prohibits Lula from associating
bolsonaro with cannibalism in the
Electoral campaign the Electoral
campaign has been dirtier than ever and
it is a Pity because policies were
needed to reactivate the Brazilian
economy the country has lost its way and
it's only sustained by the Boom in its
agro-industrial sector thanks to China's
voracious appetite for soybeans and the
rest of the products offered by the
Brazilian Countryside this is a success
story as Brazil has become the world's
third largest exporter of agricultural
products after the United States and the
European Union but this is not enough
for the South America giant the decline
of its industry continues a trend that
began decades ago look at the evolution
[Music]
the only oil and agribusiness sector
which already accounts for 28 of GDP the
rest of the industrial sector is going
from bad to worse the problem is that
the Brazilian economy is not generating
well-paying jobs such as those lost in
industry and after a campaign without
clear proposals it seems that these
issues do not matter to any politician
nor to their voters among whom are the
fanatic masses whose only objective
seems to be to defeat their opponents
that's where it fits that there are
bolsonaro supporters begging the Army to
Stage a coup against Lula they seem to
be willing to do anything although not
as much as some would have us believe
Boston Arrow supporters use their phones
to call for an alien coup some
prestigious media have fallen into the
temptation of giving varissa militude to
this new story in order to ridicule
bolsonaro's supporters billions of
Brazilians would be delighted if E.T
could heal Neymar's ankle as if it were
Elliot's finger but visualpolitik
viewers as so often happens the reality
is much less interesting than the
headlines press released fake news about
protesters in Porto Alegre although Kim
in mind we are not talking about nothing
[Music]
those cell phone flashlights directed
towards the sky are one more
demonstration of Brazilian citizens
asking the Armed Forces yet again for a
coup d'etat not the aliens or to show
off an sosfa which could capture a drone
from the sky but not the Millennium
Falcon check it out despite all this it
seems that bolsonaro has accepted defeat
and is not going to mount a trump-style
Capitol Hill the bad news for Lula is
that he will still find it much more
difficult to run Brazil than the last
time he was in office the country is
more divided than it was then and its
public finances are in worse shape
however now is the time for Brazil to
tackle structural changes and move
towards a productive model that will lay
the foundations for long-term economic
growth so what will be Lulu's main
challenges we're about to take a look
[Music]
the return of Lula
Lula de Silva wants to put the state
back at the center of the Brazilian
economy to this end he plans to use
public spending to stimulate growth
especially in infrastructure development
in Imitation of U.S President Biden's
build back better scheme he also wants
to expand social plans such as the Bolsa
Familia program however in order to do
so he has to get around a major obstacle
the public spending cap introduced six
years ago by President Tema to curb the
crisis the country was experiencing at
the time this requires a constitutional
amendment that according to some experts
needed to be approved by Congress before
10th of December so far Lula has already
indicated how much dough he needs to
make his plans a reality Lula's team
seeks to exempt 32.4 billion dollars
from spending cap and now I know that
many of you are thinking here we go they
are going to spend what they don't have
and yes it is true but bolsonaro was the
first one who dodged the spending cap
firstly on account of the pandemic but
then thinking directly about how to win
the elections the question now is how
Lula plans to pay for the extra spending
he proposes that 32 billion dollars
[Music]
Lulu speaks of policies that boost the
domestic Market in order to increase
production and consumption to achieve
this he talks about increasing social
programs public investment and
supporting infrastructure development he
argues that by generating higher
revenues tax collection will increase
but what can I say it is the Brazilian
version of the miracle of the Loaves and
Fishes the increase in tax collection
will not be enough and everything
indicates that it will put a drag on
public debt the problem is that Brazil's
finances are not the same as when Lula
left office Lula will not have much
margin for Action eighty percent of the
budget goes to public employees salaries
and pensions when in most countries
these items do not reach 60 public
spending is close to 40 of GDP a
proportion similar to that of many rich
countries but the quality of services
offered to citizens of those countries
is light years ahead of what Brazilians
receive the country needs many reforms
and the first on the list is a fiscal
reform in this respect the bolsonaro
administration failed in their attempts
now it is Luna's turn he wants to focus
on fighting inequality and improving
income redistribution quite a challenge
for Lula who fortunately will have an
easier time in other areas
[Music]
Luna De Silva is going to take advantage
of the legacy of the bolsonaro guiders
tandem although his party harshly
criticized the labor reform in the
Electoral campaign there has been no
talk of repealing it but rather of
modifying it with minor tweaks Lula also
criticized privatization but
renationalizing electrograss would have
a political cost much higher than the
millions of dollars it would require for
the transaction it would create legal
uncertainty for investments in Brazil
which would be detrimental to other
government projects such as public
private Partnerships for infrastructure
development
despite his left-wing discourse Lula has
been able to move towards the center as
evidenced by his choice of Geraldo
alkman former leader of the center right
as vice president what's more he does
not have a parliamentary majority and
this would complicate any radical
changes therefore everything indicates
that Lula will focus on improving social
plans and above all on moving forward
with a green agenda that for example
reactivates the Amazon pact for
protecting the rainforest to do that and
to develop a much more active foreign
agenda in the region Lula has said
actively and passively that Regional
integration will be one of his great
obsessions
be that as it may perhaps the main
challenge for the new Brazilian
government will really be to explain how
it will pay for its big spending
promises it will probably have to
replace the spending cap with another
mechanism that is more flexible but
capable of maintaining Market confidence
in the sustainability of public debt of
course with Congress against him this
does not appear to be a straightforward
task in any case the person lular
chooses as his minister of economy will
have a lot to say about this it seems
that he already has a name Lula is
leaning towards ex-mayor Haddad to helm
Brazil's economy Haddad is a choice from
the moderate left as mayor of Sao Paulo
between 2013 and 2016 he reduced the
budget deficit and secured for the city
and investment grade credit rating he's
not driven by populist policies and that
is good news for Brazil but now the
question is over to you do you think
that a president like Lula de Silva is
what Brazil needs or do you think
bolsonaro deserves a second term to
fully develop his policies you can leave
me your answer in the comments as always
if you found the video interesting
please like and don't forget to
subscribe to visualpolitik all the best
see you next time
[Music]